now you haven't had children yet why is
that I have not had I haven't God if I
had a minute to kind of get it together
I think that's it
Sarah that only takes a minute now
you're telling all my secrets oh man
used to take me so long I'll save you
see that's okay no no we haven't have
kids yet we're just we have been so
crazy busy I think that in the
rebuilding time it's it would be kind of
crazy to try to have a kid I mean it's
all consuming when you have a kid your
whole shift focuses to being a parent
and I I was ready to kind of do that in
my previous relationship and I thought I
was there and then you know kind of fell
apart so you know I kind of had but I
had to put it on hold because like you
said you have to be a me before you can
be a week yeah you could you imagine
being a father and in that situation but
I guess I can imagine being a mother in
that situation and coming out of it with
two children and not knowing what the I
was gonna do for number one income and
number two what I loved and what I was
passionate about I had no idea that was
like oh shoot I'm 36 and single and I
have two kids to take care of and what
the heck that was the one thing that I
was really thankful for that I didn't
have kids because it made it a much
cleaner break for you unfortunately it
was that you know living in LA and
having the the love triangle and then
the kids involved in the back and forth
and it's I I feel your pain yes you can
come to soccer next week get the four of
us in a photo for the first time in
power I actually don't have an issue
like I always sit with them or near them
and like at you know the school events
because it's gotta be bizarre well I
have no it's not at this point it's not
but I just wish we you know it adds in
flows I wish that we could get along and
then you know something will happen with
the kids and then you know just for the
kids though the three of you and then
the gears tabloids taking pictures of
their soccer game
and yeah and we're out in the middle of
like Woodland Hills the nobody goes
actually I would have to say Brittany's
kids are out there too so I got it but
it's annoying because you want to look
like crap at soccer weekend you wanna
like you want to hang on be a parent and
yeah sure if you're not to be at 9:00
a.m. okay that's a weekend I love soccer
to be at Newton gotta take take doubt
people are we get up early everyday
soccer needs to be a little later in the
day heard here yeah I'm soldered in you
and you know who you are and you know
who you are
soccer mom right